are you a destiny one player wondering
where the hell your sparrow is in the
sequel hot tip you need to wait a while
if you play destiny 1 you'll probably
have very fond memories of riding your
sparrow hoverbike around planets
doing sweet jumps and running over space
aliens if you're playing destiny 2
you'll probably also have a giant
hoverbike shaped hole in your heart
after the first few hours
well surprise sparrows in destiny 2
cannot be unlocked until you complete
the main campaign or a level 20. once
you complete the campaign pay a visit to
amanda holiday in the game's second
social hub she'll gift you a free
sparrow for all your efforts saving the
world or whatever it is that you did
so congratulations you can now purchase
additional sparrows from amanda holiday
at this same location
if you're level 20 you'll unlock the
probability of receiving one in a bright
engram whether you've completed the
campaign or not so just cross your
fingers and hope for the best
once you have a sparrow you can hoon
around with your fire team while
exploring planets and use its boost to
make sick jumps and zip to public events
even faster you can give your sparrow
custom colours with shaders
and perform hand signals and tricks with
the d-pad depending on whether your
sparrow is on or off the ground
but until you reach that moment enjoy
the slower pace of walking around
planets on foot you can still hijack
enemy vehicles like fallen pikes and
cabal interceptors which are nice when
you can get them but we recommend
soaking up the scenery
smelling the roses and punching those
space aliens for everything destiny 2
including news reviews and tips make
sure you're subscribed and you can check
out everything we've got so far
right here on gamespot
you